[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
BD WONG: Hey.
Hello, everybody.
JULIE: Hi.
BD WONG: Julie, did you just
say that I would volunteer
to take selfies with everybody?
[LAUGHTER]
JULIE: Well, yes, kind of.
BD WONG: Do you see how
many people are in here?
JULIE: Well, yeah.
I mean, we're Google, so
we can be very efficient.
We can streamline this process.
[LAUGHS]
BD WONG: How about if we
take a selfie with one person
and then green screen
in everyone's face?
JULIE: OK, we can
do that, for sure.
All of the people that want
to be in that selfie, right?
BD WONG: No, I'm happy to
take selfies, it's just--
I'm just razzing you.
JULIE: OK, thank you.
Raz some more if you want, so.
How are you?
BD WONG: I'm great.
JULIE: Yeah?
BD WONG: Yes.
You know, I'm-- you said
this already, right?
I'm a native San Franciscan.
So it's great to come home.
And it's great for my mom to
come home and do a play in--
JULIE: Oh, yeah.
BD WONG: My hometown
and stuff like that.
It's not really-- it's a big
deal for my family, kind of.
So I love it.
And I love this theater.
I've always loved this
particular theater--
American Conservatory
Theater, ACT.
And I-- so this is a really
great kind of collaboration
with them that allows me to
have this hometown experience
and to do a play like
this one that I really--
I really believe a lot
in this particular play.
JULIE: Yeah, so let's talk a
little bit more about the play.
BD WONG: OK.
JULIE: I got to see
it on Wednesday.
It was fantastic.
BD WONG: Oh, great.
JULIE: Yeah.
But I'm hoping more people here
and folks on the live stream
would come to see it.
So can you tell us a
little bit about the show?
BD WONG: Yes.
Well, Lauren-- Lauren
Yee is the playwright.
Lauren Yee is also a
native San Franciscan.
JULIE: Yes.
BD WONG: If you know anything--
I mean, there was a
big article about her
in the pink section on Sunday.
But very briefly, she
really writes a lot
from her own experience
and her own family,
and has written
two plays, in fact,
that are inspired in one way
or another by her father.
This particular play
is inspired by the fact
that her father played
basketball in Chinatown
in the early '70s and was
on a basketball team of kids
from San Francisco
Chinatown that
went to China to play exhibition
games throughout China.
And so she's written a
play about a young, very
enthusiastic Asian-American
boy in high school
who, like, wills his way onto
the team to go play in China
and kind of have
this kind of what's
it like for an Asian-American
kid to go to China experience.
And there's a lot
more to the play
and a lot more is
revealed in the play.
But the play also centers
around the relationship
between two basketball
coaches, a Chinese basketball
coach and an American
basketball coach.
And I play the Chinese
So that's it, basically.
JULIE: OK, basically.
BD WONG: And also
in its identity,
it's a comedy with a really
strong emotional undercurrent,
which is very rare
in plays to me.
I find the most
successful plays,
plays that are
successfully funny
and move you at the same time.
Did you find it that way?
JULIE: I did, yes.
And I find that Lauren's
work in particular, she just
did "King of the Yees" at
SF Playhouse, which is also
another story about Larry--
BD WONG: Yes.
JULIE: --but I
really like her work
because she does straddle humor
and touching some soft points
about family relationships,
which I think
is really heartwarming
about her work.
BD WONG: Yeah.
She's really skilled in that.
And the extra added--
I mean, I really--
I'm here to sell tickets,
right, of course--
JULIE: Please.
Please do.
BD WONG: --but I
really-- do really,
sincerely recommend
this experience
of seeing this play
in San Francisco.
And also, it's too late
to see "King of the Yees"
at the San Francisco Playhouse,
but I would definitely
have recommended that.
And when I went to see
it, "King of the Yees,"
I sat there thinking, how
was this play ever done
anywhere but in San Francisco?
The resonance was so strong.
The places that she mentions,
the locations, the things
that we all know,
or that many of us
know that we draw from our
own childhood experiences
are really strong.
And they're much stronger-- you
know, this play has been done--
"King of the Yees"
and "The Great Leap"
have been done all
over the country,
but there's something really
special about seeing San
Francisco productions about it.
They're going to be rare.
It's not-- it's a
rare opportunity.
But the one thing that I
think you might have noticed
is that the audiences
kind of like--
they just get such a
kick out of hearing
about things that they know.
And that's not an experience
you can have that often.
And I think one of the things
that regional theater does when
it's being successful
is connecting
to the community in a way that
this play, a local playwright
and a local actor,
can help them do.
JULIE: Yes, I would agree.
And it's even more special when
the audience can really relate
and visually see the locations.
I mean, in "The Great Leap,"
it's USF, it's Chinatown.
Galileo High School
is also mentioned.
And so they're already
along the ride for you.
There's not-- I
mean, you obviously
have to work for the story,
but it's kind of nice
when they're already with you.
BD WONG: When they're already--
absolutely.
And I had the really
good experience
of doing this same play
in New York last year.
And one of the major joys
of doing it again here
is my seeing the difference
of how the audience reacts
to certain things.
And I love the way
the San Francisco
audience responds to the San
Francisconess of the play.
You can feel it,
and you can hear it,
and it's really exciting.
There's a line in the play
where the American basketball
coach is telling the kid,
you know, I played and--
I went to China and I coached
the Chinese basketball players.
And they don't want
to rough each other up
and they don't want
to touch each other.
I'm paraphrasing, but
that's what he says.
And the kid says, have you
ever been to Chinatown?
[LAUGHTER]
And that line is a very
perfectly funny line
in New York City,
but in San Francisco,
the audience just loves it.
They just love knowing that the
playwright really knows what--
JULIE: Yes.
BD WONG: --pushy Chinese
people in Chinatown are--
[LAUGHTER]
--on the 30 Stockton are like.
JULIE: So true.
So, so true.
And you mentioned you did
this play in New York.
And so this is the
second time around.
What is it like to play the
character for the second time?
BD WONG: It's great.
Whenever you do a play
in a different theater,
it's going to be different.
But this is even more
so different than that,
because it's a completely
different theater
company that did the play.
It was completely different
director and different actors.
So I'm the real only kind
of consistent thing in it.
And the other big difference
is that the theater
was very small in New York.
It was a 99 seat theater.
And this is an
1,100 seat theater.
And just technique-wise
and physically,
it's a completely
different production.
It's a big set.
This version is much
more like a Broadway show
than the one we did in New
York, where Broadway is.
So that experience is
really a learning experience
for somebody like me,
because you're always
surprised at the
new things that you
can discover when the play is
opened up in a much bigger way.
JULIE: Right.
BD WONG: Lots of
things, like there's--
I have more costumes
in this production
than I had in the
first production.
And usually you'd
think the play,
the storytelling of the play
requires certain characters
to wear certain costumes
at certain times.
And that's true, but I was able
to, because the theater was
so small, wear the same thing
throughout the entire play.
And it worked really well,
because that character
was consistent throughout,
from 1971 to 1989.
This time, because it's
so opened up and big,
when I walk off the stage
and I come back on again
and it's a different
time period,
you kind of want to see
me dressed differently.
JULIE: Yeah, you want
to see the progression.
BD WONG: And so I was really
kind of thrown off at first.
Like oh, I'm going
to wear all these--
like the first day they show
you all the sketches and stuff.
And I was really
surprised at that.
And then my mind had to
click over to, oh, I see.
I see this differently now.
And that is an example of a lot
of different things that have
happened-- the way you use your
voice and all of that stuff--
that are adjustments and
learning experiences.
JULIE: How has it
been just performing
for some of the early audiences?
I saw it during a
dress rehearsal,
so I know that was the
first time you were up.
BD WONG: Well, a play like this
with a lot of fast language
and a lot of--
at least one of
the four characters
in the play that has a lot of
movement, and a lot of staging.
And then there's physical
elements in the production,
like moving scenery
and stuff like that.
These things take
such time to iron out.
And so there's never
been such a thing
as a perfectly brilliant
dress rehearsal,
because you're still
working things out.
You can never be that ahead
of schedule that by the time
the audience comes,
it's all down.
Your mind is always
processing things.
So we did a pretty clean
skate on that dress rehearsal,
but the show has definitely
deepened and deepened
and deepened.
And we've done it maybe
six or seven times now.
And it's almost--
it's pretty much
hit its stride as far as the
command that we have over it.
JULIE: Right.
BD WONG: And it's like
practicing anything,
right, over and over again.
The more you do it,
the better it gets.
And with this kind
of play, which
is kind of deep and kind of full
of lots of details and stuff,
it's a kind of a
bottomless well, you know.
You don't ever get bored of
it, because there's always
something new to
discover about it.
JULIE: That's the beauty of
theater and live production.
BD WONG: Yeah, and
good plays, and plays
that are written with
a kind of substance.
JULIE: Especially when you're
in love with the play, too.
BD WONG: Yeah, I do--
JULIE: You do it all the time.
BD WONG: I do.
And this particular play
is one of my favorite plays
that I've ever been able to do.
I love doing it.
I could keep doing it forever.
I understand why actors like
Carol Channing and Yul Brynner
played parts forever and ever.
I used to think
they were losers.
[LAUGHTER]
I used to think, oh, god.
Put it away, Carol.
You're 80 years old.
And she's going on tour with
another tour of "Hello Dolly."
She maybe did seven--
and Yul Brynner--
seven or eight tours of the--
but when that part sings for
you, you want to keep doing it.
And you know what you're
giving the audience.
And they're loving it.
There's no way that you're
going to give that up.
So I don't see myself continuing
to do this play until I'm 80,
but I understand the joy that
one gets from that, yeah.
JULIE: Yeah.
I mean, you could
certainly do it,
because it has that
age progression--
BD WONG: Yes, it does.
JULIE: --and you certainly
don't age at all.
BD WONG: Yeah, OK.
JULIE: [LAUGHS] What
I really walked away
with from the play was that
it's about manifesting destiny.
And there's two
characters, and one
is able to just kind of
move through the world
and say, yes, everything is
on my plate and I can grab it.
That's Manford.
And for your character,
it's more or less
like waiting for the
opportunity to be told,
like, it's now your time.
And there's a line
at the end where he--
and I'm going to paraphrase
as well-- but like basically
saying that I didn't
know that it was my time,
but now it's my time.
It's always been there.
BD WONG: Yeah.
JULIE: And I'm
wondering how that
parallels with your successful
career that you've had.
BD WONG: Oh, wow.
I never made a--
I never thought to parallel it
that particularly personally.
I have always
considered him someone
that I needed to learn
about, because he,
being a citizen of
Communist China, what
was built into that life,
particularly in this time
period, was a life of giving
yourself-- giving over
your own wishes to the
wishes of the party
and not making
choices for yourself.
And what's a nice
juxtaposition in the play
is that this balls to the
wall Asian-American kid who
doesn't know anything
about that, just
wants and is going
after his dream.
JULIE: Yes.
BD WONG: And in comparison,
this other character in China
is giving up all of his
dreams, because there's
no alternative for him because
of the political circumstances
that he is in.
Personally, I guess
what I could say
is that when I was
in high school,
I was just so lucky to have had
a very mentorial relationship
with a high school drama teacher
who recognized potential in me
and who absolutely
demanded that I follow it,
or that I not squander it.
To the point where she took me
by the hand to my own parents
and said, I really
think this person
needs to keep doing this.
JULIE: Wow.
BD WONG: And my parents were
rather typical Asian-American
second generation parents.
They weren't super,
super, super--
they weren't tiger parents.
They were more, though,
conditioned and assumed
that the best thing
for us would be
successful and stable careers.
Doctor or lawyer, that was it.
That was it.
JULIE: Yes.
BD WONG: And so that
was a huge paradigm
shift for this person who
was kind of an expert, right?
She knew.
She was a drama teacher.
Not really, but she did have
credibility for my parents.
And so the idea-- when you say
the idea of taking your shot,
or looking, following your
bliss, or taking what you think
could be yours, that
came from outside forces
that I was lucky to
have been exposed to.
And I guess I do
relate emotionally
at the end of the
play to someone
who isn't able to do that.
And whatever the complicated
feelings that one
has not having to have that
restriction, the guilt you
might feel, survivor's
guilt kind of thing,
or it what if it
were me, really,
we're all here just
because we're here.
We don't get a choice to
be Communist Chinese or not
Communist Chinese.
And in this particular
play, it really
shows that you
don't have a choice.
JULIE: Yes.
BD WONG: And so I
think we all kind
of take for granted our
freedom and our ability
to do whatever we want and
to say whatever we want.
And the play very, very
beautifully reminds us of that.
And I do like that
part about the play.
So I do relate to the
character's inability
to access his dreams based upon
my ability to access my dreams,
I guess.
JULIE: Yes.
It's interesting
because a lot of times,
even like if we take the context
out of the play of just being
maybe an emerging
artist of color,
or part of the LGBTQ
community, which you have been
a huge advocate for both, I
think it's quite difficult when
we are going out to pursue
those kinds of artistic dreams,
whether it be in acting,
dance, or even here in tech,
if you don't see
a role model, it's
hard to really think
about, can I go out
and grab hold of those dreams?
And it was great that you
mentioned your high school
mentor.
But as someone who may
not have that, what
is some advice that you would--
BD WONG: Well, I--
advice, I have tons of advice.
But before I give advice,
I think it's-- and it is
important to acknowledge that
phenomenon of representation.
We're in this point
now where we're
talking about
representation all the time.
And it doesn't lose its meaning,
but what I love to talk about,
what is absolutely essential
about that representation
is the influence that
that representation has
over younger people, right?
And that what we're
really fighting
for in our grown-up
state is, well, we
want to see more Asians.
But I want to see--
I want my stories to be told.
I want to see sexy Asian
people on the screen and all
of that stuff.
But what we really want is
for the needle to shift,
because our kids don't
have the same schism when
it comes to looking,
searching fruitlessly
for themselves in the media.
And it is shifting in a way
where the exposure is greater
now.
And we do love that.
And so my advice would
be, I don't know,
I think it's partly--
for me, it's always been
kind of that hokey Gandhi
thing, that be the change
you want to see thing.
That there's always someone
that you can mentor.
There's always someone--
even if you're not famous,
there's always someone that
is looking to you for--
and as role models,
I think people
forget that that thing
is really happening.
You don't see it happening.
You don't feel it happening.
But it's happening
Young people are
looking to you for an example
of what they are going to be.
They have no other
frame of reference
but to see a person older and
more experienced than them
and to do as they do.
JULIE: Yes
BD WONG: And so our
self-esteem is super important
and our sense of sorting
out all the baggage
that our parents gave us and
their grandparents gave them.
Sorting all that so that it's
a little bit easier for them
is a fun challenge, I
think, because we're still
dealing with our own baggage.
But I think we do have
less, a little bit,
than our grandparents had.
JULIE: I hope so.
BD WONG: We have
different kinds.
Our grandparents didn't
care about representation.
JULIE: True.
BD WONG: They don't
care at all about it.
But then I do remember my
parents' generation of people
running into the
living room saying,
oh my god, look there's
an Asian person on TV,
like that kind of thing.
And us all running
into the living room.
That wasn't that long ago.
And there is still a
sense of that now, right?
Oh, look.
Wow, it's a commercial
with an Asian person in it.
That's kind of a new
trend, commercials
with Asian people in them.
[LAUGHTER]
Well, because for
whatever reason,
we could talk about it
forever, about the misnomer
that Asian people, their
money doesn't matter
or something like that.
JULIE: Something like that.
BD WONG: So now it's
clearly true that--
it's been established that
the money does matter.
And that's good for us in a way.
And it's certainly good
for our representation.
JULIE: Oh, totally.
Yeah, and I mean the success
with "Crazy Rich Asians,"
I mean, proved that it can
be a commercial success.
BD WONG: Right,
that it transcended
being an Asian movie by being
popular across the board, yeah.
JULIE: Everybody, yes.
And that's what's really nice.
I did hear on a podcast that you
did maybe a couple weeks ago,
KQED, what really struck
me was you did talk
about the responsibility
that you have,
or producers, or people who
have that power of choosing
the story, that they
have this responsibility
to create these images and
characters so that the younger
generation can be inspired.
So I'm wondering, what is
your personal responsibility
for that?
Are you having a hand in
developing [INAUDIBLE]
BD WONG: Oh, yeah.
You mean what am I doing?
JULIE: Yeah.
BD WONG: Yeah, I am.
I think that's
one of the great--
one of the things that
comes out of frustration
is the creative limitations
that you're given.
Create, if you're up
for it, opportunities
for yourself, or for
others, or for the people
that you believe in that are
experiencing the same kind
of marginalization as you.
And so I have--
I'm always working
on things on my own,
like trying to maintain my
relationship with theaters
like ACT to kind of like--
I'm already thinking,
now, what's next?
What would I do here next?
And coming up with, you
can't just pick one thing.
You can't just go
to Pam MacKinnon,
the artistic director,
and say, oh, here's
the one thing I
want to do, do it.
You have to give her
a landscape of things
that might work and see whether
any of them appeal to her.
And all of those things for
me involve Asian-Americans,
or not just me or me as
a character playing--
they're all explorations of
re-imaginations of classic work
or new work itself that will
do what this play that we're
doing now is doing.
When I talk about
producers, I'm not
sure exactly what
I said that time,
or don't remember
exactly, but I do
feel that there's this
phenomenon that we're all
well aware of that's
very frustrating that we
don't know what to do about it.
And that is that
unless it affects you,
you often don't want to do
anything about something.
It's the kind of thing-- to
use a very brutal example,
it's like the people that
are most championing cancer
research and stuff
are people that cancer
has touched themselves, right?
And this is a kind of way,
in some ways, for people
to choose the things
that mean most to them,
which is a nice thing.
However, when it
comes to Hollywood,
the issue of diversity doesn't
ring true for a lot of people.
And it kind of defines
white privilege,
what we like to throw around,
this term of white privilege.
Because a person has no
sense of what that damage
or what that pain or what
that exclusion feels like.
So the ones who are
doing it are doing it
because they know they're
supposed to or whatever.
So some way to get them to feel
that is the thing that I think
is an interesting challenge,
to get them to understand,
to take to heart.
It's the equivalent of
going to a cancer benefit,
like a big cancer
gala or something,
and watching the
video that they show
of what it means to a survivor
or to their family or whatever.
And you're going, oh,
those are human beings.
I relate to being a human being.
That thing, I don't
have to have cancer
to know that this is important.
JULIE: Yeah.
BD WONG: And that
kind of sharing
of that, because there are
still so many producers
and people that are borderline.
They're either doing it because
they think they're supposed
to-- and that's good, but
they're still not really
feeling it--
or they don't get it at all.
It doesn't occur to them.
And I'm fascinated by
that, because I personally
am really--
I don't consume a lot of
things that are all white.
Like when I see something that
seems kind of like it's all
white or doesn't have any
Asian people in it at all,
I'm not as interested.
I don't connect to it.
And so, like I
watched the other day,
I watched "Hidden
Figures," which everybody
loves that movie, right?
It's a great-- it's a
very satisfying movie.
But I'm less moved by it.
I feel left out of
it in some ways.
Because as we grew--
as I've grown up, it was always
like, are you black or white?
There was like a
kind of question
that was a very strange one
to perceive people asking.
Anyway, I don't know.
That's just me going
on about that question.
JULIE: I love it.
BD WONG: OK, thanks.
JULIE: It's very interesting.
But I kind of want to tag back
on to what you just said about,
well, I'm not a part of it.
And I think that's the narrative
that a lot of Asian-Americans
feel, that we're not part of
the main narrative in Hollywood.
BD WONG: Right.
JULIE: Kind of to tie
back to Lauren, and then--
I know we're talking
about "The Great Leap,"
but the "King of the Yees" made
a comment about, in marketing,
there's the black
people marketing,
the Hispanic people--
BD WONG: That's right.
She talks about it, yeah.
JULIE: --marketing, and
then there's Asians.
And we're all lumped into
the Caucasian marketing
plan, which I thought was
a very interesting point.
And I'm wondering, how do we
get more visibility out there?
Like how do we raise our
voices and say, hey, we matter,
or make more stories about us
because we want to watch it?
BD WONG: Well, I would tie
that into my being here today,
really, because what
I'm trying to do--
I mean, the theater
wants me to come and talk
about the show, which is great.
And I love talking
about the show.
But what I really want
to do is to create
a situation in which
Asian people are really
supporting their own content.
Because the only way to
perpetuate that content
is for it to be successful.
And if Pam MacKinnon, the
Caucasian-American artistic
director of American
Conservatory Theater,
has a big dud with
this play, she's
less likely to do another one.
And then we're all more
likely to complain about it.
And we're like, oh, well,
ACT, they don't ever do--
well, did you go?
Did you go see it?
JULIE: Exactly.
BD WONG: And for
Asian-American people,
well, with a lot of
people, like human beings,
they don't always understand
the gesture of that.
Like doing your part, voting.
All of that stuff.
Yes, it does matter
that you vote.
And yes, it does
matter that you buy
a ticket to see a play if you
care about what the play can
do for you, the things that
you're complaining about,
that we all complain about.
So that's an equation that I
think could be made more clear.
And I love that.
And I always try to
tell people, oh, just
try to support the content.
And we really did that in a big
way with "Crazy Rich Asians."
JULIE: Yes.
BD WONG: That was really
super gratifying to me,
and reassuring to me,
and encouraging to me
that this generation of
Asian-Americans put their money
where their mouth was,
and created a sense,
whether it's true or not,
that something has changed.
Because there's a lot of
articles out there now saying,
has it really changed?
Or whatever is it.
What will happen next?
There's a fair amount of
"Crazy Rich Asian" knockoff
action happening out there,
which is a really good sign--
JULIE: That's great.
BD WONG: --that--
I'm not into knockoffs but
I'm into the representation--
[LAUGHTER]
--so I'll take it.
But it's absolutely--
like there's
going to be a couple
of television shows
and all of that stuff.
And that's really good.
You do have to kind
of, in some ways,
if you're really,
really responsible,
you take note of the people that
are sponsoring Asian content
and try to support them.
That's what network
television is kind of--
one thing that it
allows you to do
is to see the corporations
and the companies that
support the things that
we're trying to do.
So we don't think
about that, right?
I don't think
about it that much.
I have to go, OK, oh look,
OK, so these people are
sponsors of the whatever show.
I don't know, whatever it is.
I'm doing this Comedy Central
show with Aquafina in summer.
JULIE: That's right.
BD WONG: And I can't wait to see
who buys ad time on that show.
JULIE: OK, last question.
I'd love to know what your
mom thinks about all of this--
[LAUGHTER]
--because moms are important.
BD WONG: Yes, we are at the
Asian Affinity Google Group,
aren't we?
JULIE: We are.
And mommies are important.
BD WONG: Really, I have to
say, I consider my mother way
more than I should in
various everyday decisions,
like buying underwear.
I'm just so-- it's so deeply
ingrained to me to please her
that I think about
her to a fault.
And it's not necessarily
good for me sometimes,
but I do do it.
And there are really positive
side effects of that.
And I must say that choosing
this play, to do it here,
and to do it here now, and to
kind of drop everything as much
as I could to do it, because the
time commitment that it takes
to do a play is really intense.
And that means being
away from home.
And I have a teenage son
and all of that stuff.
So choosing to do
so, to do a play out
of town, was made infinitely
more seductive or satisfying
because my mom's here, and
because my mom is inviting
my whole family, my
whole, gigantic--
her whole family, who mostly
are still in the Bay Area,
to come to the
matinee this Sunday.
And then to have this big
party upstairs in the theater,
and do that kind of thing.
Because she is like a--
there isn't one
prototypical Chinese mom,
but there are
maybe four or five.
[LAUGHTER]
JULIE: Yes.
BD WONG: Right?
BD WONG: And my
mom is the one who
will do anything not to brag
by using bragging words.
[LAUGHTER]
If you look closely, there is
a lot of bragging going on,
but it's very classy
and it's very--
she never says anything.
She lets everyone else say nice
things, and then she says--
she just nods or
something like that.
You must be very proud.
[LAUGHTER]
So she is in that kind of--
it's kind of passive aggressive,
like she doesn't want to--
but it's wonderful to be the
beneficiary or the recipient
or the inspiration for
her doing these things,
inviting all of her family
and friends to this thing.
And not pushing them to come see
it, but telling them when it is
and hoping that they come
and then feeding them.
JULIE: That's key.
BD WONG: Yeah.
Food talks, yeah.
BD WONG: And she's kind of
a mascot of the production,
because the last time
I worked at ACT, she
cozied up to the house staff.
And so then she would
say to me, oh I'm
going to go shopping
in Chinatown.
I think I'm going to come and
see the second act of the play.
And show up and they'd like
let her sit in the back
or whatever like that.
I said, well, you
can't just show up.
I mean, you have to meet
the person or what--
but she is-- she's treated very
royally and it's very nice.
JULIE: It's very [INAUDIBLE].
BD WONG: She's like
the Empress Dowager.
[LAUGHTER]
And she's very cute.
And she has a very
lovable personality.
She really does.
She's just like-- she's
very infectious and very
kind of smiley.
JULIE: I love that.
BD WONG: Yeah.
JULIE: That's great.
Thank you, BD.
We have our first
question over here.
BD WONG: OK, you're on.
AUDIENCE: Hey, BD.
BD WONG: Hey.
AUDIENCE: I'm also-- I notice
that you're a native San
Franciscan.
I know we've talked a
lot of serious topics,
but we wanted to talk
about something fun.
Julie mentioned food talks.
BD WONG: Uh-huh.
AUDIENCE: And I'm always curious
about when actors come home,
at least back to San
Francisco-- or actresses--
what's your go-to?
What is the one
thing when you come
back here that you need to have,
that kind of connects you back
with your childhood and some
of these good, joyous memories?
BD WONG: Capital Restaurant,
Clay Street, chicken wings.
JULIE: Oh.
BD WONG: They're
famous chicken wings.
And they're-- I mean,
I'm almost kind of like--
you almost want to not
tell people about them
because you want
them for yourself.
But that comes to
mind immediately.
My family is obsessed
with the House
of Prime Rib on Van Ness--
obsessed with it.
[LAUGHTER]
And we go there--
we like, I mean,
at the opening of an
envelope, we will go there.
It's like we'll go
there for any occasion.
We'll make up some special
occasion to go there.
JULIE: Of course.
[LAUGHS]
BD WONG: And so we do the House
of Prime Rib whenever we can.
We just did it a
couple weeks ago.
Let's see, what else is there?
Sunset Bakery, [INAUDIBLE].
That's on like 9th
Avenue in Irving.
Or [? Judah. ?]
And let's see, what else?
Let's see, I'm going through
all of my ethnic groups--
Mexican.
[LAUGHTER]
You know, my Uncle Bobby, my
mom's brother, replicated the--
you guys are mostly
too young for this--
but my Uncle Bobby replicated
the recipe of the enchiladas
at this place
called The Hothouse,
which was at Playland
at the beach, which
was by the Cliff House,
this boardwalk that
used to be there.
And there used to be like a
pass-through window rest--
kind of a precursor to a
food truck kind of restaurant
called The Hothouse.
And they had these very basic
but delicious enchiladas
that came in a little
cardboard tray.
And so my uncle has
kept that recipe alive
and makes a big batch of this
enchilada gravy that they made.
And so that's a childhood
memory of going to The Hothouse
at the beach.
Because I grew up
on 40th and Ortega,
really close to the beach.
Those are the top five, I think.
The ones that-- there'll
be more that come to mind
and I'll blurt them
out like Turret's.
JULIE: Please do.
AUDIENCE: Sweet, thank you.
BD WONG: Sure.
JULIE: We'll go right over here.
AUDIENCE: Thanks again
for coming today, BD.
BD WONG: Sure.
AUDIENCE: This is a little bit
more of a personal question.
So I went to acting school
in New York many years ago.
When I graduated, it
was the early aughts,
and I walked into
an industry that
was not particularly looking
for dudes who looked like me.
BD WONG: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And I wanted to
talk-- you talked a lot
about representation today.
BD WONG: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I wanted to
talk a little bit more
about the pipeline issue.
And for me, I got
out of the game.
And I'm very ashamed
to admit that.
And it was really hard for me.
But I had those
prototypical parents
who were like, chase your
dream, chase your dream.
And then it became, I
can't do this anymore.
BD WONG: Right.
AUDIENCE: So I guess my
question is, what would you
say to all of the folks who now
are going into an industry that
is just slightly more
friendly to folks like us
to keep them in the
game, and to keep
that side of the [INAUDIBLE].
BD WONG: Oh, great.
That is a really good
positive-based question.
Thank you.
And you know, good
things come from pain.
And if your pain
created this question
and changes somebody's life,
that's probably a good thing.
But I will say that--
just before I answer--
is that pain, that
rejection, and that shame
are universal, right?
They're not your own.
And you have to blame,
really, the situation
much more than yourself
for the outcome of that.
You seem perfectly happy
now, so I trust that that's--
AUDIENCE: We'll see.
BD WONG: Yeah, yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
And what I would say--
well, I wouldn't
say anything that's
that different from what people
told me when I first started,
when it was
considerably different,
which was if you absolutely
have to do it, then do it.
And if you don't, you should
think of something else.
It's super difficult. It
messes with your mind.
It messes with your self-esteem.
It messes with your sense of
self-worth, your sense of what
success means.
And you have to be--
you have to have an
extremely strong constitution
and an extremely
accessible support system.
And I feel like you're right
that the needle's moved
to the point where
young people--
you want to kind of
slap them for the things
that they complain about, right?
Because it was so much harder
before and it is so much--
there's so much more
opportunity now.
But with that opportunity
comes more competition.
And I certainly feel that from
the beginning of my career,
there was less competition.
And the competition has
grown and the amount
of younger people in
the industry has grown.
But so, also, has the amount
of Asian-American writers
and the amount of
producers and people
that are actually making
influential choices.
So I would just say
that they really
should not take for granted--
especially given
what you're saying.
They should not take for granted
any progress that's been made.
But you know, young people
are so clueless sometimes,
and rightly so, because
we can't know anything
that happened before us.
We can hear about it and
we can take it to heart.
When we talk to my son, who
was born in 2000, about 9/11,
he understands
the gravity of it.
He doesn't feel
the emotion of it.
He wasn't there to
watch on television
the absolute
devastation and the loss
and the emotional feelings.
So you guys know that this
show, "Come From Away,"
came into town a few weeks ago.
"Come From Away," is
centered around the day
of 9/11 and the days after.
And it's one thing where
if you're of a certain age
and you're sitting in the
audience at that show,
everyone in the
audience is having
the same emotional experience,
which is a very rare thing.
In Lauren's play,
she's having to explain
certain really heavy things that
have happened in its history.
And you get it
from understanding
what she's taught you about it.
"Come From Away" starts
and it says, today's 9/11,
and everyone starts
crying immediately.
And it's kind of great.
Anybody born after 9/11
doesn't really understand.
This is a tangent
to try to describe
these rather adorable young
people that are becoming actors
don't really understand
the things that
were built on the backs
of other people, right?
This is an ongoing discussion
about everything-- about AIDS,
about gay people and AIDS,
and about the Holocaust,
and everything major
that has ever happened,
where every pain that any
generation has experienced
is really hard for the
following generation to feel.
So we cut them a
little bit of slack.
And we try to kind of--
for me, I think a
sense of discipline
and a sense of entitlement.
Discipline needs
to be encouraged
and entitlement needs to
be kind of smacked out
of people sometimes.
But the advice I would give is
that it requires an absolutely
steadfast constitution.
And that there's great
joy to be had in it,
and that there's
something actually
kind of noble about it.
There is a sense, that I learned
from my first acting teacher,
that you are a messenger,
and that if the messages
that you're giving are
true and are positive
and they make people think
or they make people act
differently, then
you've done something,
or you've acted as an agent to
something actually happening.
So it's not just kind
of glamour and acting
and applause and
stuff like that.
It could be rather
useful in society.
So thank you.
I appreciate that.
JULIE: Thank you.
We have a question over here.
AUDIENCE: Hi, BD.
Thanks again for coming out.
Just wanted to
ask you a question
as an Asian-American
who's also grown up
with second generation parents.
If you ever traveled back to
China, if and when you did,
did you ever--
how was that experience for you?
And how were you
channel that when
you're acting during the play?
BD WONG: I went to
China two major times.
The first time I went,
my dad was still alive.
And I was booked to
be the guest speaker
on a cruise that went to China.
And it was a super-duper,
hilariously fancy cruise
with all super old white people.
But I was supposed to talk about
being a Chinese person to them.
I was like-- it was a
little bit like a zoo.
[LAUGHTER]
You know, it's like
feeding time is at 4:15.
BD Wong will come out and you
can throw pretzels at him.
[LAUGHTER]
But it was a really, really, in
many ways, moving experience.
My dad had not been back to Hong
Kong since he left Hong Kong.
Oddly enough, my grandfather
was born in California.
My grandfather went back
home to marry my grandma
and to have my dad and
then brought them back.
So my dad was technically
not born here,
but he was born a citizen.
And so he had this
very, like, oh my gosh,
this is where I was born kind
of thing that really snuck up
on him.
I don't think he ever even
thought about going back,
but here was this opportunity.
We went back.
So that was that.
And I wish I could talk for
an hour about this cruise.
It was so funny, because--
JULIE: Sounds amazing.
BD WONG: Well, first
of all, I will tell you
that the one thing is it was
so fancy that they give you
this little thing to fill
out when you come in,
when you check into your room.
And the thing asks you
what kind of liquor
they want you to stock the bar
with, the refrigerator with.
And you get four bottles of
each, or something like that.
And my mom is a
white wine drinker
and my dad was a Jack Daniels.
Drinker.
So they got four
bottles of white wine
and four bottles
of Jack Daniels.
And then that night they put all
eight bottles in their suitcase
and they filled
out the form again.
[LAUGHTER]
JULIE: Of course.
BD WONG: By the
end of the cruise,
they had like a
BevMo under the bed.
[LAUGHTER]
I don't want to say--
it's racial profiling
to say that this
is because they're Chinese.
But no pun intended.
You do the math.
[LAUGHTER]
I went on a second
trip to China in 2003
to make a terrible
television movie.
But that was a really
interesting cultural experience
for me as well, working
with Chinese people
and working in the Chinese
film industry in rural China.
And I think, really, I hope
you'll come see the play.
Lauren talks about the
experience of being
an Asian-American and going
to China as a very unique kind
of odd fish-out-of-water
experience.
And that is THE
experience I felt.
I didn't really feel like I
was home or anything like that.
I felt-- it's so obvious to them
that you're American before you
even open your mouth.
You just, you can't hide it.
And so there's always either a
curiosity or a slight disdain
over you.
And so I felt that tension.
And that was no
different than the way
that the young woman in the play
describes it in Lauren's play.
So apparently,
Lauren understands
that kind of experience too.
It's pretty common.
Did I answer the question?
Not really.
AUDIENCE: You did, or kind of.
[LAUGHTER]
BD WONG: You said good
things, but you did not
answer the question.
[LAUGHTER]
JULIE: But we learned
about the BevMo.
BD WONG: What was the
specific question?
I can answer it now.
AUDIENCE: I guess--
BD WONG: Oh, how did I
draw on it in the play?
Well, I would say that--
how did I draw on
it for the play.
I did really relate
it to Lauren's words
about being an Asian-American
going to China.
And I think what I had to do,
really, the research about how
shut down a Chinese
person who's not
a dream seeker, a person who is
of a certain constitution who
is a party member of the--
a member of the party
and very obedient
and very diligent.
That is a very different
kind of person than me.
And so I did have
to kind of access
whatever else I
feel in my life that
shuts me down, or quiets me, or
keeps me from making decisions.
And I do relate to feeling like
a younger man being closeted
and feeling kind of restricted
by my sense of being closeted,
and a sense of not being
able to be free and open
and speak my own truth.
So that's the thing
I would relate to,
I think, more than going
to China, actually.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
BD WONG: Sure.
JULIE: Thank you.
BD WONG: I'm just going back and
forth, because it makes sense.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
So I think a lot about inequity.
It's a very heavy topic.
BD WONG: Yes.
AUDIENCE: I think a
lot about inequity.
And one thing I've been
thinking a lot about
is the importance of
Asian-Americans needing
to leverage their
privilege in order
to stand in deep solidarity
with other communities of color.
So black and brown communities.
And I know, obviously, there's
a nuance in various industries.
I think the tech industry,
we're highly represented here.
And that looks different
in other places.
But I wanted to hear
a little bit more
from you around how you think
about Asian-Americans building
that solidarity with
other communities of color
in the entertainment
industry, and what you
see happening on that front.
BD WONG: It's such
a wide reaching,
far reaching industry, right?
You have Hollywood.
And here we are, I'm working
at a regional theater.
And the regional theater has
its own agenda and aspirations
for community building and for
community fundraising and all
of that stuff.
And they're different, I think.
The wider Hollywood industry
is driven by a bottom line
kind of thing that makes it
really hard for this needle
to shift.
And I don't know if
actually this-- this might
be a similar kind of tangent.
But what your question
is reminding me of
is my own baggage
about fundraising,
like for example, when I'm
pushing up the mountain
several of my own projects.
I've co-written a
musical that I'm
trying to continue to develop.
And I have, say,
several other projects,
a lot of theater projects.
And I find myself--
one of them is one that our
friend has been involved in,
a mutual friend, which is a
very diverse cast of actors.
And other projects are
Asian-American projects.
And I find myself
trying to edit myself
when it comes to whose
money I'm going after.
Like I [INAUDIBLE]
think, oh, you
can't ask an
Asian-American person
to help me fund the
diverse project.
You should really be getting
the Asian-American person
to fund the
Asian-American project.
But I think, well,
wait a second, though,
but I'm the Asian-American
making this project.
Will that be enough
for them to support me,
to help move the
needle in that way,
because my work as a writer
will be put on the map.
And then I will be able
to have the credibility
to create more and more content.
And as it turns out, this
particular diverse project
ends up having a lot
of Asian people in it.
But it's not an Asian project.
And so is there a kind of--
what I'm saying
is that I perceive
there to be some kind
of invisible limit
to the amount of
support I can get
from the Asian-American
community,
like from Asian people
that have money.
I think, oh, I have to be really
careful about who I ask money
for and what it's for.
They'll want me to just--
they'll want me to just do
all Asian content I think.
And so that's interesting,
because I guess what I--
as am repeating it--
I'm an Asian-American artist
and that's the content
that I'm generating.
But I know that doesn't
really specifically answer
your question.
I'm also just me and I don't
really understand or know
what's going on out
there, necessarily,
about the connections between
different groups and how--
You know, Ken Savage,
who was up here before--
no, was he up here yet?
No, he wasn't up here yet.
Ken Savage, who works at ACT
and brought me here today,
was talking about how he
has been in this building
before, because he also did
a Google talk with the Black
Google Live group.
JULIE: BGN, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
And so that shows
you that that kind
of accessing the different
groups within the theater
is an active thing
that's happening.
But I think you're
absolutely right.
That kind of solidarity
is really helpful.
I think everybody
has their own agenda
and their own unique
challenges, and that sometimes
makes things difficult,
as you can imagine.
JULIE: Yeah.
Thank you so much
for your questions.
We are out of time.
AUDIENCE: Really?
JULIE: Yeah, I know.
It's been so much fun.
I'm sorry for those who
couldn't ask the questions.
But BD, I just want to thank you
so much for being here today.
And for those who don't know,
please go watch the show.
It's running at ACT Geary
stage, "The Great Leap,"
until March 31.
So thank you again.
[APPLAUSE]